and dakota hudson is going to make the
start for the cardinals he's 2-0
lifetime against the pirates
then it brings in josh belt
that's taken low and a pick off at first
and got him yachty picked him off with
the quick throw and tag by goldschmidt
how many times have we seen that
countless in his career the one two
and a ground ball
and it's a momentum shift in the first
inning already thanks to yada yada man
and that's something that he just does
such a good job of this afternoon in st
louis the pirates will send mitch keller
the rookie right-hander colton wong at
second base leading the cardinal lineup
he has three for eight so far this year
with a triple and a walk
one for four last night a couple of hits
friday
lefty hitter keller's next pitch
fastball up in the zone and it's popped
up toward right center and going back
jarrod dyson that ball carried
on dyson and he makes the catch and he
bangs up against the padded wall
jose osuna is their right fielder today
and he's at the plate now with the man
at first base start the runner is
swinging a miss throw a little offline
doesn't matter quick tag by wong and a
caught stealing so yachty already making
his presence felt
as he winds and fires
swaying and a miss and a strikeout two
in the inning two of the game
and it brings in the switch hitting
dexter fowler
hung it but
it hangs up there for us sooner
jose osuna for the pirates squeezes it
it is nothing nothing one out in
the bottom of the third and st louis
lane thomas
gets his first start in center field the
2-1 pitch
called ball three and you hear
jordan baker just threw out
we don't know yet
who it was but he just threw out someone
in the dugout
he said knock it off
now part of an argument is you got to
put on your mask
we'll find out who got tossed but uh
somebody barked something at jordan
baker and he didn't like it the pitch
goes high and that's ball four for lane
thomas
we've gotten confirmation now that derek
holland has been
rejected golden wong the second baseman
comes up here's the one-two pitch
breaking ball in the dirt
and now the runner takes off for second
and he over slides second base eric
gonzalez
applies the tag on lane thomas who
initially was safe as he tried to
advance on the pitch in the dirt but he
over slid thomas broke for second on a
ball that was dropped by their catcher
but stallings allegedly picked it up and
then through and here's a shot into left
center of base set for wong
so two outs extends the inning to tommy
edmond
the pitch tommy takes it in the dirt and
that ball
rolls up the first base line after it
was blocked by starlings and cole wong
goes to second on a wild pitch rbi
opportunity for tommy edmund the pitch
to him edmond chops it
backhanded by moran race to the bag and
save wong trying to score to the plate
he is safe
edmond the second heads up base running
here by the cardinals now runner's
second one nothing cardinals paul
goldschmidt at the plate the 1-0 pitch a
swing and the ball is popped up
second baseman the shortstop shade their
eyes the second baseman frazier calls
for it on the third base out of second
he makes the catch
facing colin moran
shift on the right side in the 2-2 pitch
moran drives one to right deep to right
and this one is out of here a home run
for colin moran
the first bucco home run of 2020 belongs
to the redbeard
number one and it ties the game at one
jose osuna comes to the plate
oh soon at the plate hudson's pitch
and a line drive toward left center
field that is deep and that is gone
clearing the deck in saint louis with a
cannonball
jose osuna
gives the pirates a 3-1 lead in the
fourth and it brings in josh bell
3-1 count bases loaded
converse got to come to him the pitch
and it's a high fly ball to
right center center fielder will make
the catch runner at third will tag and
score
and the pirates take a 4-1 lead on the
sacrifice fly by josh bell
moran has hit a home run today up at the
plate
first and third are the runners
four to one pittsburgh
and the pitch
swinging a ground ball a cardinal first
baseman has it unassisted
and that'll uh take care of this fifth
name
jose osuna who homered in the fourth
left-hander brings it home
as osuna shoots it in the gap in right
center there's thomas on the run to make
the catch nice play jt brubacher is
going to the hill for the very first
time colton long today has lined the
center field he has singled and scored
here's the 3-2 payoff pitch we're gonna
miss struck him out with a breaking ball
so brubacher
makes his major league debut and he gets
his first strikeout here's paul
goldschmidt
in the bottom half of inning number six
in st louis the 1-1
goldschmidt hits at the left for a base
hit reynolds gets over
knocks it down he's gonna try for two
he's out what a throw brian reynolds
nabs goldschmidt at second in the inning
here's tyler o'neill he's capable of
tying the game with one swing here's the
offering from brubacher and it's a fly
ball towards center
gerard dyson is there to make the catch
two outs phillip evans is coming up
evans has been on with two hits today
bell dances off to a lead at first
here's the swing phillip evans now lines
one to deep left field going back o'neil
it's over his head
and
bounces at the base of the wall bell
being waved home here comes the throw
not close
phillip evans with his third hit of the
day
and this one an rbi line drive double
over tyler o'neill's head it's 5-1
pirates as bell scores from first jose
suna now
jose osuna hit a two run homer in the
fourth inning
the pitch swung on grounded up the
middle to his left the young has it the
shortstop throws out osuna
it brings in the last garden of hope the
designated hitter
matt carpenter
the stretch by birdie and the pitch
and there's that breaking ball and
appeal and he rings him up for the
strikeout and raise the jolly roger as
derek shelton is doused with some
bottled water from his players that
are on the bench and some of his coaches
as the pirates win